seine bücher sind bestseller fotos
landauf und landab bitten ihn zum
interview und er hat eine eigene nach
ihm benannte talkshow richard david
precht der philosoph sein geheimnis er
weiß wie man komplexe dinge verständlich
macht für manche freilich treibt recht
es gar zu bunt mit seinem erfolg er
mische sich zudem in themen ein von
denen er selber nicht genug verstehe so
zum beispiel mit seinem neuesten buch an
die schule und der liebe gott recht
fordert darin nichts geringeres als eine
totale bildungs revolution nicht länger
wissen eintrichtern sondern kreativität
und selbständiges denken fördern das ist
was brecht verlangt und zwar subito hat
den streitbaren intellektuellen
eingeladen
richard david precht sie äußerten sich
öffentlich zum afghanistan krieg sie
haben eine meinung zum leben als paar
sie haben was gesagt zur frage der krise
der demokratie und sie haben gesagt max
frisch sei kein besonders guter autor
verstehen sie dass es leute irritieren
kann dass sie zu allem öffentlich eine
meinung haben
also ich glaube die meisten menschen
haben auch zu all diesen verschiedenen
aspekten eine meinung nur haben nicht
die sie nicht die gelegenheit die an
vielen stellen öffentliche kunst zu tun
aber warum sollte man wenn man starke
meinungen in bestimmten bereichen hat
sich nicht öffentlich einmischen und
gerade aus der perspektive eines
philosophen heraus sollte man das tun
in der zeit als die philosophie ihre
größte bedeutung hatte und es gab ja
eigentlich nur zwei zeiten in denen sie
mehr wirklich bedeutend war das war
einmal in der zeit der krise der
attischen demokratie bei platon und
aristoteles und es war in der zeit der
aufklärung wo die ganzen grundlagen für
die bürgerliche gesellschaft geschaffen
werden verdienen staaten in denen wir
heute leben und in diesen zeiten haben
philosophen sich massiv eingemischt und
so in alle erdenklichen bereiche sie
waren für die naturwissenschaften
zuständig sie haben sich über
musiktheorie geäußert sie haben sich in
der politik eingemischt sie haben sich
in juristische fragen eingemischt
also ich halte dass wir das ganz
selbstverständliche aufgabengebiet eines
jeden philosophen und zu max frisch
gesagt ich habe eigentlich nichts böses
über max frisch gesagt mich hat gestört
dass max frisch immer noch eine der
wichtigsten schullektüren überhaupt er
sondern es gibt eine ganze reihe
andere autoren die mindestens ebenso
interessant sind die nicht in die
lehrpläne kommen und das hat mich
gestört
naja immerhin haben sie gesagt sie
finden seine literatur nicht besonders
gut was natürlich eine schweizerin ein
bisschen irritiert aber lassen wir das
mal beiseite
interessant finde ich ja was sie immer
wieder betonen dass eigentlich die
platonischen dialoge sowas sind gerne
hochblüte sie haben auch in ihrem buch
die kunst kein egoist zu sein haben sie
gesagt tun ist so etwas wie der erfinder
der talkshow sokratis der gastgeber und
da kriege ich dann den eindruck das
scheint ja für sie zu sein aber so kapp
es fällt ja auch auf durch die these ich
weiß dass ich nichts weiß diese kann
heute bescheidenheit ja ich weiß gar
nicht ob das so anmaßend und so
unbescheiden es sich einzumischen und
die gedanken die man gemacht hat
öffentlich zu äußern
das bedeutet ja nicht dass man sich im
besitz einer exklusiven wahrheit wählt
ja grundsätzlich alles besser weiß als
alle anderen sondern das heißt dass man
sich in discos einmischt die
gesellschaftlich wichtig sind weil man
glaubt sie aus einer bestimmten
perspektive oder mit einer bestimmten
haltung konfrontieren zu sollen
es bedeutet nicht herr über die wahrheit
zu sein interessant ist auch dieses
phänomen alle fragen sind sie werden
sehr viel angefragt für interviews wenn
man sie googles dann kriegt man ganz
viele treffer auch gerade die in fotos
interviews mit ihnen und gleichzeitig
beschimpfen sie diese verschiedenen
freut uns auch es gibt nicht besonders
schmeichelhafte beschreibungen ihrer
person sie wurden sofort kritiker
bezeichnet man hat mal gesagt sie seien
ein bildungsportal es ist ein lifestyle
philosoph oder der philosoph im
außendienst beleidigt sie das eigentlich
wenn sie so bezeichnet werden wenn sie
in der öffentlichkeit stehen und das
gilt für mich aber das gilt genauso für
andere menschen in der öffentlichkeit
stehen denken sie etwa an politiker da
müssen sie diesbezüglich sehr viel
aushalten können gerade in deutschland
und das hat sie auch verschafft also
gehe der tonfall mit dem man menschen
angreift hat sich in den zeitungen in
polizei aber fangen auch in den
vergütungs radikalisiert seit es eine
internet kultur gibt und man sich ein
teil auch dieser vögel kultur des
internets abgeguckt hat und entsprechend
starke urteile fällt vernichtende
urteile
fällt also das halte ich für einen
allgemeinen trend und ich bin glaube ich
keine ausnahme
was vielleicht ein bisschen besonders es
ist dass die funktion die ich in der
gesellschaft übernehmen die eines
öffentlichen philosophen eine ist die in
deutschland sehr lange kaum besetzt war
und in deutschland auch eigentlich gar
keine vertraute position ist also wenn
sie in frankreich schauen 99 prozent all
der dinge die in den fertigungs in
frankreich über mich geschrieben sind
sehr positiv in deutschland dagegen
erleben sie sehr sehr viel negative
kritik auch sehr viele helme
das liegt daran in frankreich hat eine
tradition von öffentlichen
intellektuellen das heißt in der
funktion in der ich in deutschland bin
gibt es in frankreich fünf sechs sieben
leute die mir sofort einfallen würden
die eine ähnliche position bekleiden
frankreich hatte eine andere tradition
deutschland hat diese tradition nicht
und dafür gibt es auch ein grund nach 45
waren die philosophischen
geisteswissenschaftlichen eliten wenn
sie nicht im exil waren diskreditiert
und dann hat man diese intervention
dieses einmischen in die wichtigen
gesellschaftlichen debatten nicht von
philosophen erwartet sondern von
schriftstellern gruppe 740 nicht also
denken sie eher weiter jens und günter
grass und martin walser die haben sich
auch zu allen erdenklichen themen
geäußert habe interveniert
gesellschaftlich stellung bezogen
man hat gedacht dass ich die aufgabe der
dichter und in den letzten zehn jahren
hat das große jammern angefangen darüber
die dichter sind so unpolitisch geworden
und die schriftstellerischen sich nicht
mehr ein und dergleichen der schweiz
auch die sehnsucht nach einem neuen
frisch oder nach einem neuen dürrenmatts
wir stellen dir das macht aber die rolle
des schriftstellers in der gesellschaft
hat sich eben sehr stark gewandelt
doch die rolle der literatur hat sich
gewandelt literatur muss heute sehr viel
unterhaltsamer seien im regelfall als
sie früher war sie muss einer filmischen
dramaturgie folgen also das ereignis
reicher sein plot points haben und damit
wird natürlich auch ein anderer typus
des schriftstellers hervorgebracht und
das ist dann häufig nicht immer aber
häufig jemand der ihnen kann ich nicht
mehr interveniert und das ist ja
eigentlich für sie ein bisschen die
gunst der stunde sie sind enorm
erfolgreich ein bestseller-autor finden
sie das eine gute sache finden sie das
wirklich eine gunst der stunde finden
sich mal mit plage dass sie zu allem
befragt werden
ich will mich mich
insofern beklagen dass ich sage es ist
eine plage aber sie können mir glauben
dass ich ungefähr vier fünftel aller
anfragen im hinblick auf talkshows
interviews oder einmischung ablehne es
ist also sowieso schon sehr selektiv ich
gehe im jahr vielleicht drei oder vier
mal in eine talkshow
aufgrund der anfragen könnte ich das
deutlich häufiger tun aber ich empfinde
mich ja auch nicht selbst als ein
experte für alles ich werde sehr häufig
in talkshows an gefragt wo ich mir
sofort jemand ein feld das sehr viel
besser kann und sehr viel besser weiß
als ich dann im zweifelsfall vom kann
sie nicht genommen wird weil eine
öffentlichkeit nicht so bekannt ist
wir sind sie in experte na ja also ich
denke es gibt in der philosophie einige
bereiche die fachspezifisch das sind was
mich am meisten interessiert und das ist
hier ganz sehr schnittstellen bereich
zwischen biologie und kultur
das ist sozusagen das wo ich
fachwissenschaftlich philosophisch zu
hause und das andere was ich mache ist
der versuch verschiedene diskurse in der
perspektive der wechselseitigkeit zu
beleuchten und dadurch neue evidenzen
oder klarheit zu schaffen
das heißt also in dem unübersehbaren
dickicht der verschiedenen diskurse und
wissenschaften die uns umgeben so etwas
zu machen die pfade zu schlagen oder ein
bisschen was erhellen wie es dazu
beizutragen das sind eigentlich die beim
rückspiel geben
na ja also ich habe in dem buch wer bin
ich und wenn ja wie viele das ja
ursprünglich jugendbuch war einfach mal
zu versucht zu gucken wo stehen wir in
den wichtigen menschheitsfragen heute
aus verschiedener perspektive was haben
hirnforscher dazu zu sagen was haben
primatenforscher dazu zu sagen nicht was
wissen evolutionäre psychologen sagen
soziologen als ist ja ein ganz breites
tableau von einem primatenforscher frans
de waal der darin vorgestellt wird zu
einem soziologen niklas luhmann
ich habe einfach versucht mit der
taschenlampe mal in den nachthimmel zu
leuchten und den stern zu zeigen und den
stern und den stern von dem ich sage das
könnte wirklich interessant sein das
könnte uns etwas grundsätzlich weiter
helfen in den wichtigen fragen da stehen
wir heute mit unseren debatten und das
alles in einer sprache die für ein
möglichst breites publikum verständlich
ist denn wenn philosophie nur für
experten verständlich ist wird sie in
einer mediengesellschaft unweigerlich
bedeutungslos werden
denn das was in den scheinwerfer nicht
wahrgenommen wird
was in den großen debatten nicht
wahrgenommen wird das kürzlich in der
gesellschaft irgendwann aus über die
funktion der philosophien wie man sie
verstehen sollten wie man sie übersetzen
kann möchte ich später auch noch weiter
mit ihnen sprechen
ich möchte jetzt zuerst noch reden über
ihr neues buch anna die schule unter
liebe gott daran darin diagnostizieren
sie ja eine bildungskatastrophe im
ersten teil des buches und sie sagen
unsere kinder werden mit den falschen
inhalten mit den falschen methoden an
den falschen schulen abgefüllt warum
soll ich ihnen dieses vernichtende
urteil abnehmen
ich weiß nicht ob sie mir das abnehmen
müssen ich überlege mir in was für eine
lebenswelt werden diese kinder ein
geboren in was für ein erlebnis welt
werden sie später leben
wie wird das berufsfeld dieser kinder
aussehen zwei drittel der kinder die
jetzt eingeschult werden werden
mutmaßlichen berufen arbeiten die es
noch gar nicht gibt aber wir haben eine
ungefähre vorstellung davon was diese
kinder in einer wahnsinnig komplizierten
lebens und berufsfeld später mal können
müssen
und wenn ich merke sowas bilden unsere
schulen kinder aus und was ist das was
in diesen 10.000 13.000 stunden in den
kinder in die schule gehen was müssten
sie eigentlich in dieser zeit lernen
man sehe ich da ein eklatantes
missverhältnis und das ist der grund für
diese vernichtende kritik es gibt gute
lehrer
es gibt gute schulen aber das gesamte
system ist relativ falsch ausgerichtet
sie werden im grunde genommen in der
schule zur chefsekretärin ausgebildet
das heißt ihr ansatz ist sozusagen dass
sie leute ausbilden wollen menschen
ausbilden wollen für die zukunft wie
eine bestimmte setting in der zukunft
und ihre sorge geht nicht so sehr den
kindern liest ihnen heute jetzt in der
schule gibt bisher dazwischen überhaupt
kein widerspruch
also die kinder die jetzt in der schule
gehen die werte nein das gleiche wollen
was jeder auch wird ein erfülltes leben
haben und dann teil dieses erfüllten
leben ist aufs berufsleben das heißt ich
will die kinder jetzt nicht auf einen
ganz bestimmten beruf hin die seinen das
würde ich so absolut ablehnen
zumal wir ja gar nicht wissen in welchen
berufen die kinder später arbeiten aber
ich möchte sie für das wovon wir relativ
sicher sein können dass werden die
herausforderungen in ihrem leben sein
da möchte ich ihnen alle chancen geben
ein solches leben zu leben
und der positive effekt davon ist dass
die schulen dann auch
die kinder so wie sie gegenwärtig sind
sehr viel angenehmer sein werden und ich
hoffe für die allermeisten kinder die
werden sich auch deutlich mehr wohl
fühlen als sie das häufig jetzt in den
schulen würden und woher wissen sie die
schulen jetzt sind ich kenne natürlich
sehr sehr viele schulen also ich kenne
sie aus der perspektive als vater ich
kenne sie aus der perspektive selber in
die schulen gegangen zu sein und ich
habe mir ganz viele ganz
unterschiedliche schulen angeschaut
ich habe mit sehr vielen lehrern
gesprochen ich habe mit schulleitern
gesprochen ich habe mit kultusministern
gesprochen ich habe mit leuten aus
stiftungen gesprochen und leute die
netzwerken aktiv sind und dergleichen
und mir versucht innerhalb eines
überschaubaren zeitraums da eine
vorstellung zu also die erfahrungen
ihres sohnes spielen ja an diesem buch
auch immer wieder eine rolle system so
geht das er am morgen aufsteht und
schule in split gehen gar nicht so toll
findet sondern das spiel gibt zwischen
ihnen und ihrem sohn dass man spielt
jede gehen in die schule
aber eigentlich hat man gar keinen bock
drauf schon selbst motivationstraining
fast schon aber als philosoph wissen sie
eigentlich von der eigenen erfahrung auf
allgemeine prinzipien zu schließen ist
gelinde gesagt gefährlich meinen sohn
kommt nur einmal ausführlich vor der
einleitung eines einzigen kapitels und
ich möchte das schulsystem nicht für
mein sohn verändern
mein sohn lebt in vergleichsweise
privilegierten umständen und er kriegt
auch sehr viele anregungen aus dem
elternhaus und ich bin ziemlich sicher
er wird seinen weg gehen ich will das
schulsystem nicht für ihn ändern ich
werde das schulsystem vor allen dingen
für all die vielen kinder und das sind
wirklich viele ändern
die all diese chancen durch das
elternhaus nicht an und das ist mein
hauptanliegen
mein hauptanliegen ist nicht für die
kinder von privilegierten die schulen
schöner zu machen und eine kernthese
dass sie sagen wissen ist heute nicht
überbewertet um welches wissen geht es
ich glaube dass in den schulen die mir
vorschweben menschen im grunde immer
mehr lernen als heute weil sie mit
weniger stoff konfrontiert sind wenn sie
und das ist als erwachsener genau dass
er wie sie als kind ganz ganz viel stoff
in ganz kurzer zeit bewältigen müssen
dann wird das wird ihnen jeder
hirnforscher erzählen und ihre
entwicklungspsychologe und jeder lernt
theoretiker von all dem sehr sehr wenig
ihnen bleiben wenn sie sich mit weniger
lang und intensiv beschäftigt haben ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie da
wissen ablagern und zwar nicht nur im
sinne von vorratsdatenspeicherung
sondern im sinne von etwas was sie aktiv
gestalten können auf das sie
zurückgreifen können dass sie auf
anderes beziehen können also das was wir
unter bildung verstehen dass man nämlich
verschiedenes wissen kreativ aufeinander
beziehen kann und etwas eigenes daraus
machen kann eigene gedanken entwickeln
kann
das alles können sie dann besser wenn
sie nicht mit so viel stoff in berührung
kommen also das was wir normalerweise in
der schule machen ist viel zu viel stoff
in viel zu kurzer zeit und lernen
psychologisch schlechtesten durchdacht
denn wenn sie 45 minuten chemie machen
und dann machen sie 45 minuten englisch
und dann machen sie 90 minuten matte und
dann 45 minuten geschichte
stellen sie sich das mal in einem
normalen berufsleben vor sie müssen sich
mit so unterschiedlichen dingen ins auf
so kurzem raum überhaupt beschäftigen
das ist lernt psychologisch alles
völliger unsinn
und dann stellt man sich die frage warum
macht man sowas in der schule und man
macht das aufgrund einer tradition als
man es nicht besser wusste und einer
tradition die 100 oder 150 jahre alt ist
und heute wissen wir dass alles besser
und was ist die alternative wie sollten
wir es machen
ich stelle mir vor dass man nur in den
ersten sechs schuljahren im
klassenverband unterrichtet weil die
kinder in diesem alter einen
entsprechenden nestwärme brauchen
und weil es bestimmte dinge gibt die
alle kinder in dieser zeit lernen müssen
zum beispiel rechnen schriftlich rechnen
mit oder sich gute rechtschreibung zu
schreiben sich mündlich gut ausdrücken
zu können
eine ganze reihe von sachen wo man sagt
als sind auch bildungsziele das sollte
jeder wissen da wo sich ihre ahnung von
haben und das machen wir in den ersten
sechs jahren und anschließend gibt es
einen strang individualisiertes lernen
das ist jenes lernen was sie am besten
alleine machen können im eigenen
lerntempo und den bei größeren schrank
dass sie die schulen projekte auflösen
wo sie in zusammenhängenden sinn
komplexen etwas lernen es gibt ja ganz
viele bereiche die in unseren schulen
gar nicht vorkommen weil es die fächer
nicht gibt zum beispiel wirtschaft etwas
was in den allermeisten deutschen
schulen überhaupt nicht vorkommt aber
eines der wichtigsten dinge überhaupt in
ihrem späteren leben
warum nicht ein projekt zum thema geld
anbieten so in diesem projekt zum thema
geld
kann ein sozialwissenschaftler arbeiten
da kann ein ökonom der vielleicht mal
bei einer bank gearbeitet hat ein
ehemaliger sparkassendirektoren daran
beteiligt sein
das heißt leute aus allen erdenklichen
berufsfeldern auch lehrer
unterschiedlicher fachrichtungen machen
zusammen ein solches projekt oder ein
projekt über die goethezeit oder für
kinder mit ganz anderen interessen ein
projekt automotor wo ein leibhaftiger
kfz mechatroniker mit den kindern
zusammen am automotor bastelt also ich
möchte erstens die trennung zwischen
schule und leben überwinden
und ich möchte diese falsche vorstellung
dass die welt des wissens aus fächern
besteht überwinden und sagen mach doch
etwas was das kind freiwillig wählt weil
es sagt ja ottomotor das finde ich geil
dass wir nicht spannend wenn es sich in
diesem projekt betätigt und ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es etwas lernt
was dauerhaft von belangen ist sehr viel
größer als wenn wir in fächern dieses
von kritikern oft sogenannte bulimie
lernen praktizieren also ganz schnell
wissen reinstopfen wie ein test oder
nach der klausur wieder von uns geben
und anschließend vergessen so geht
lernen gar nicht ein stück weit habe ich
mal das gefühl gewisse dinge zumindest
die kenne ich sogar noch aus der eigenen
schulkarriere also dieses projekt lernen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist die
schweizer an einem anderen punkt wie
deutschland wir haben im moment in der
schweiz eine grosse debatte über den
sogenannten lehrplan 21
das ist das erste mal dass alle
deutschschweizer kantone sich einen
gemeinsamen lernplan geben wollen
er ist gegenwärtig aber noch in der
konsultation und darüber gibt es einen
großen streit unter anderem darüber dass
man gesagt hat man will keine lernziele
mehr sondern man will das aufheben
zugunsten von überfachlichen und
fachlichen kompetenzen und das ist
eigentlich etwas glaube ich was sie auch
betonen es soll irgendwie und
kompetenzen geben hätte ich mir das aber
irgendwie noch zu schwammig was worum
geht es denn genau also kein wissen rein
rein pressen was ist das ziel was sollen
wir denn wissen oder lernen
das ziel ist können etwas können wir
können also fähigkeiten entwickeln die
fähigkeit jedes kind was von der schule
kommt sollte möglichst die fähigkeit
besitzen in freier rede sich gut elegant
im zweifelsfall humorvoll und wie auch
immer artikulieren zu können
ganz ganz wichtig ist hier kommt ein
ganz großer teil unserer abiturienten
oder realschüler von hauptschülern gar
nicht zu reden können das gar nicht ist
ein ganz wichtiges unterrichts ziel sein
weil sich mündlich gut auszudrücken ist
eines der wichtigsten eigenschaften die
sie für ihr leben und für ihr
berufsleben brauchen
das kann man die kompetenzen ich kann
das sprachkompetenz nehmen ich bin nicht
so ein riesen freund dieses wortes
kompetenz dann kann man nämlich ganz
lange listen mache ja also
problemlösungskompetenz soziale
kompetenz emotionale kompetenz
konfliktkompetenz und so weiter und dann
wird eigentlich etwas wo wir über das
die feine unterwäsche einer
persönlichkeit reden sagt in lauter
fachbegriff kompetenzen da reden wir
eigentlich als wenn wir über maschinen
reden aber was die sache anbelangt dass
es darum geht dass man wenn man von der
schule kommt bestimmte dinge kann mit
fehlern umgehen können mit seinen
eigenen fehler mit den fehlern von
anderen im team arbeiten können
eine präsentation machen all das was wir
in diese kompetenz begriffe packen als
eine persönlichkeit haben jemand sein
der sich selbstständig in neue
wissensgebiete einarbeiten kann und zwar
nicht nach schema f sondern den eigenen
weg in einem komplizierten dickicht zu
finden das sind alles fähigkeiten wir
brauchen sie im leben gebrauchen sie im
berufsleben und von diese fähigkeiten
die stehen im mittelpunkt der schule und
das sind ja eigentlich nicht nur
fähigkeiten von denen man vielleicht
sagen kann man brauchte später im leben
sondern sind das stück weit ja auch
wertungen die dem zugrunde liegen welche
fähigkeiten die den kindern mit auf den
weg geben wollen und auch darüber gibt
es einen streit im lehrplan 21 mal in
diesen überfachlichen kompetenzen da
gibt es genau solche sachen die
kritikfähigkeit die fähigkeit
freundschaften einzugehen
solche fähigkeiten wie man den den
kindern mitgeben
aber auch so etwas wie umgang mit geld
umgang mit medien
die svp sagt in ihrem gegen lehrplan na
ja wo sind andere werte
ähnlichkeit ordnung pünktlichkeit wer
darf denn darüber bestimmen welche werte
schule machen sollen
ich glaube ich wunder mich über den
streit weil ich sehe kein gegensatz
also pünktlichkeit ist eine frage der
selbstorganisation
pünktlichkeit ist ein wichtiger wert und
ich muss mich selbst gut organisieren
können dass ich von mir aus werke und
lerne ja das möglichkeit wichtig ist und
dass ich das hinbekomme also ich habe
das gefühl ist die künstliche grenze
pünktlichkeit ist genauso ein wichtiger
wert wie soziale kompetenzen und vieles
andere mehr
ich würde da überhaupt nicht drin man
wenn man ein bisschen die zeit zurück
spielt dann gab es vor ein paar jahren
diesen riesen streit über das buch lob
der disziplin von bernhard wird wo man
sagen muss der na ja da gab es ja schon
die frage wie viel disziplin soll sein
und wie viel sollen die die kinder
ermutigen einfach ihren weg zu gehen
darauf vertrauen dass sie ihre ihr
potenzial entfalten also wieviel
sozusagen härte braucht es in der schule
und um vielleicht noch eins
draufzusetzen
sie plädieren ja auch dafür die noten
abzuschaffen verstehen sie dass gewisse
leute sagen hier hast du bist ein
kuschel pädagogik abbrechen
also ich verstehe dass wenn man das buch
nicht gelesen hat und wenn man nur hört
die noten abschaffen dann kann ich
verstehen dass da ein anti reflex kommt
und wenn man mir erzählt hat sie mit
jemand behauptet man sollte im
gegenwärtigen schulsystem die noten
abschaffen
dann würde ich sagen also ich wieviel
spinnerei ist das denn
ich bin dagegen im gegenwärtigen system
die not nach zu schaffen aber ich bin
auch gegen das gegenwärtige system und
ich sehe auch diesen unterschied nicht
zwischen disziplin auf der einen seite
und selber wählen von projekten wenn ich
selber projekte wähle wenn ich mir
selber ziele setze was brauche ich dafür
selbstdisziplin
die entscheidende aufgabe ist auch mit
hilfe von disziplinierung menschen zur
selbstdisziplinierung zu bringen das ist
die aufgabe wenn es aber nur bei der
disziplin bleibt also wenn ich nur
diszipliniert bin weil ich sanktioniert
werde dafür aber nicht selber lernen
selbst diszipliniert umzugehen
dann macht disziplin keinen sinn aber
ich glaube da wäre wo er vermute ich
jedenfalls gar nicht anderer meinung
also ich sage ihnen ich kinder geht mal
in die schule und dann denkt ihr euch
aus was wollt ihr denn gerne machen und
noten gibt es sowieso nicht sondern es
gibt eine struktur die
den herausforderungen der zukunft aus
meiner sicht deutlich besser angepasst
ist
indem man selbst diszipliniert auch sein
muss das auch etwas was man lernen muss
in dieser struktur aber mit den noten
sieht das einfach so aus warum bisschen
dass noten seien zwischen 16 oder einer
oberstufe in deutschland zwischen 1 und
15 oder 60 punkte in frankreich das sind
ja völlig willkürliche setzung und wir
alle wissen dass noten ungerecht sind
also wenn sie im sportunterricht als
fettleibigen kind sich enorm anstrengen
dann haben sie eine chance vielleicht
eine 4+ wegen guten willens zu kriegen
wenn sie ein modellathlet sind in der
sowieso neben ihrem sportverein ist dann
können sie das alles von alleine kriegen
1 also was bewerten sie denn da sie
bewerten talent das gleiche machen sie
musik das gleiche machen sie im kunst
das machen sie auch in mathe auch da
bewerten sie sehr weitgehend talent und
für talent kann keiner was also ist die
frage ist doch irgendwie einfach so das
leben ist ja keine hensel die schule
sollte auch keine insel sein und wir
müssen die kinder und die schüler auch
von morgen gegen ja auch darauf
vorbereiten müssen die haie war ich doch
steht dann bin ich auch für ich will ja
den bewertungen nicht abschaffen der der
sinn einer ziffern zensur ist eine
vergleichbarkeit in einer klasse
herzustellen wenn ich nach dem sechsten
schuljahr keine klasse mehr habe brauche
ich keine zensuren mehr aber ich brauche
immer noch bewertungen
wenn ich in dem projekt automotor dem
projekt goethezeit mich engagiere dann
bekomme ich nachher von den leuten die
dieses projekt gemacht haben den lehrern
und den leuten aus dem leben bekomme ich
eine bewertung und so sammle ich eine
mappe mit bewertungen wie ich mich
eingebracht habe was ich gut gemacht
habe was ich besonders gut kann was ich
nicht so gut konnte und so weiter das
heißt es entsteht im grunde genommen
eine persönlichkeit biografie die ist
sehr viel aussagekräftiger als wenn ihr
meine vier in chemie hat dann weiß ich
nicht warum hat henri 4 in chemie weil
er die hälfte der zeit gefehlt hat und
nichts mitgekriegt hat weil er zu faul
war weil er kein talent für chemie hat
das heißt eine solche note ist nicht
aussagekräftig ich möchte sie durch
etwas aussagekräftigeres ersetzen nun
zum thema wettbewerb im gegenwärtigen
system konkurrieren die kinder weil der
klassendurchschnitt darüber entscheidet
wie die note ausfällt konkurrieren sie
gegeneinander
das ist ein falsches verständnis von
konkurrenz denn das ist nicht typisch
menschlich menschen konkurrieren nicht
als individuen gegeneinander sondern in
gruppen in der evolution des menschen
waren nicht tausende von
steinzeitmenschen der jeder auf sich
allein gestellt werden der jeder gegen
jeden an kontrolliert hat sondern man
hat sich zu horten zusammengeschlossen
zu familien zu verbänden zu claims und
das ist die normale art der konkurrenz
das ist auch die konkurrenz die
unternehmen zueinander haben das sind ja
nicht einzelpersonen die da
gegeneinander konkurrieren sondern das
sind unternehmen die auf einem markt
miteinander konkurrieren warum wollen
wir diesen gedanken nicht in die schulen
tragen
warum untergliedern wir diesen anonymen
käufer der schule ein direktor 100
lehrer 1000 schüler nicht in lauter lärm
häuser also nach dem vorbild der
englischen coaches also gryffindor und
severin und wir lassen
harry potter was genau wir lassen diese
lern häuser gegeneinander konkurrieren
spielerisch konkurrieren das heißt ihr
könnt kopfrechnen wettbewerber gegen
dann da machen die können sich im sport
miteinander messen können
vorlesewettbewerbe machen die können
theaterprojekte entwickeln die dann
gemeinsam irgendwo präsentiert werden
und diese hat er konkurrenz steigert
zugleich die kooperation und den
gemeinschaftsgeist innerhalb eines
lernen hauses und lang können sie das
positive des wettbewerbes mit der
anderen positiven seite verbinden
nämlich mit dem einüben von solidarität
diese idee der lern häuser harry potter
den sie ihn immer wieder auch in
interviews anbringen
da kann man ja aber schon mal gegen
sagen naja diese diese schule von harry
potter das ist eine elite zauberschule
es gibt knallharte noten wer sich nicht
anständig benimmt fliegt von der schule
also die individuen da drüben sind ganz
schön unter druck
also ich sage gerne griffen und
stripperin damit die leute sich was
vorstellen können der grundgedanke ist
eigentlich das englische college system
und das englische politischen system war
wiederum die vorlage von harry potter
aber ich möchte nicht einfach das
englische system übernehmen sondern ich
schaue überall wo gibt es etwas gutes
und wie könnte dieses gute miteinander
zusammen passen wie könnte man aus all
den verschiedenen guten ansätzen die es
gibt manche sind 200 jahre alt andere
100 jahre alt andere kommen wäre es aus
den letzten zehn jahren
wie kann man das so zusammen setzen dass
man ein
ein faires bild für eine schule der
zukunft entwirft mir geht es ja auch
nicht darum dass nachher jede schule
genauso aussieht das wäre eine
fürchterliche vorstellung eine soziale
brennpunkt schule hat ganz ganz andere
probleme und herausforderungen als eine
schule in einem villenvorort sondern ich
möchte dass wir ein bild malen wie
ungefähr könnten und sollten schulen in
zehn jahren aussehen
und dann möchte ich dass man den schulen
eine sehr große gestaltungsfreiheit gibt
aus diesem angebot und aus diesen
möglichkeiten das ihre zu wählen und
nach maßgabe der kinder geht man halt
der eltern die die kinder auf diese
schule schicken etwas in diese richtung
nach eigenem gusto zu machen sie haben
immer wieder betont wie wichtig es ist
dass das kind selber sich entwickeln
kann und dass man ihm selbstorganisation
beibringt dass es auch in projekten
verantwortung selber übernehmen ist für
seine lern karriere
es gibt immer wieder lehrer und
lehrerinnen die sagen dass es mit totale
überforderung für viele kinder für die
intelligenten mag das klappen aber für
viele kinder ist es einfach schwierig
sich selber zu organisieren um selber in
irgendwelchen projekten zur arbeit und
machen sie sich diesen klagen weil die
kinder das nie gelernt haben aber es ist
nicht allein wenn man das von den ersten
blick also bei uns in der schule war das
so in den 70er jahren kam plötzlich die
neue idee projektwoche rund 40 konnten
wir in projekten was machen da hat man
gedacht jetzt müssen wir nach all dem
was wir lernen gelernt haben müssen wir
das ergänzen das wurde also eine ganz
normalen unterricht an gepflegt das
gleiche gilt für plötzlich kam die 68er
lehrer in unserer schule die habe ich
alle mit gekriegt als ich zwölf jahre
alt waren kamen die in die schulen und
dann sagten die macht doch mal
gruppenarbeit
ich habe gesagt diese gruppenarbeit aus
sie sah so aus dass derjenige der sich
am meisten über seine zensur gesorgt hat
die ganze arbeit gemacht hat und die
anderen haben nichts gemacht warum weil
wir bis dahin noch nie wirklich
gruppenarbeit gemacht haben und wir
wurden damit alleine gelassen
man kann nicht irgendwelche methoden mit
gewalt und wo einführen aber man kann
vom kindergarten in kindertagesstätten
in die schule
eine solche kultur entwickeln und wenn
sie sich besonders gute schulen angucken
ich kann da nur beispiele aus
deutschland bringen also die freie
evangelische schule in berlin zum
beispiel wenn sie diese kinder erleben
wie selbst organisiert die sind wenn sie
sehen wie rhetorisch frei die sind wie
großartig die sich ausdrücken können im
alter von 11 12 13 jahren dann deswegen
weil das eine von anfang an unterstützte
kultur in dieser schule ist und sie
können das nicht ruckartig machen
sondern sie müssen es stück für stück
wissen sie es aufbauen und müssen ein
solches klima eine solche kultur in der
schule entwickeln und dann werden die
kinder im alter von 12 oder 13 jahren
die allermeisten durchaus in der lage
sein ihre neigungen zu folgenden
projekte zu wählen und sie werden ja
nicht allein gelassen
ich sage ja nicht einem zwölfjährigen
kind passt mal auf hier gibt es sieben
projekt gesucht die am 1 aus sondern ich
habe hier diese lernen häuser in diese
lern häusern gibt es lehrer die kennen
diese kinder seit sie drei jahre alt
sind
die haben ihren ganzen weg verfolgt die
beraten ihnen die helfen ihnen die
coachen sie bei dieser wahl also dieser
grundsätzliche gedanke der pädagogik
lasst die kinder alles selber
entscheiden oder selber machen den halte
ich für kokolores aber eine kultur zu
etablieren in dem die kinder lernen
eigenverantwortung zu übernehmen
das halte ich für nicht sie selber sind
ja in einer familie aufgewachsen in die
es auch viele regeln gab viele werte gab
ihre eltern waren pazifisten sie waren
grüne sie waren vorher marxisten bist du
denn er reif terroranschlägen muss ein
bisschen sicher dann politisch
orientiert haben hin zu den grünen
sie haben selber zwei geschwister
leibliche geschwister zwei adoptivkinder
waren auch noch in der familie kinder
aus vietnam die man adoptiert hat aus
protest gegen den vietnamkrieg sie haben
auch in interviews gesagt sie durften
nicht cola trinken jeans waren tabu
popmusik war tabu sie sind selber
eigentlich mit ganz vielen
wertvorstellungen aufgewachsen
glauben sie dass hat sie irgendwie
geprägt jetzt für dieses buch zum thema
bildung ja es gab sehr starke
wertvorstellungen meiner familie und das
halte ich für gut und richtig und es ist
halt sehr beklagenswert dass wir viele
familien haben in dem diese art der
werteerziehung leider nicht gut
funktioniert das ist sicherlich ein
viertel oder fünftel der bevölkerung wo
die kinder eigentlich keine werte mehr
von zu hause mitgenommen haben und
wichtig ist ja auch dass diese werte
nicht erzählt werden sondern sie gelebt
werden
sie glauben sie wirklich keine werte
haben sie nicht das sind vielleicht
einfach andere werte ja ich glaube das
sind schon viele familien bei den
die kindererziehung so vernachlässigt
ist das ein wertebewusstsein gar nicht
entsteht das glaube ich tatsächlich
leider so viele und aus diesem grund
jetzt ist ja wichtig dass die kinder zum
frühest möglichen zeitpunkt das dann
bekommen von der schule beziehungsweise
ein kindergarten ich habe mich nicht
unbedingt beliebt damit gemacht dass ich
gesagt habe ich möchte dass wir eine
kindergartenpflicht in deutschland haben
wo die kinder von drei jahren in den
kindergarten gehen
das tun die allermeisten kinder in
deutschland sowieso aber es gibt einen
kleinen prozentsatz von kinder die das
nicht tun und das sind kinder sehr
häufig aus migrantenfamilien die ist
gerade ganz ganz nötig hätten dass sie
da hingehen aber solange keine pflicht
besteht gegen ihn nicht dahin
und dann sind es kinder der
besserverdienenden den ich hier hingehen
weil die mutter ist sich leisten kann zu
hause zu sein sie und die kinder zu
kümmern weil der mann viel geld verdient
und die ganz heftig und energisch
protestieren dass sie ihre kinder drei
stunden am tag weiter von drei jahren in
eine kindertagesstätte oder im
kindergarten geben sollen ich glaube
dass es nicht anders geht wenn sie
schauen was aus all den kindern wird die
jetzt aus einer sozial desolate familie
kommen und auch nicht in einen
kindergarten gehen
die sind wenn sie mit sechs jahren in
die schule kommen für sich und die
gesellschaft bereits verloren da können
sie schon bei der einschulung sehen der
wird nie einen schulabschluss machen und
wird an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit stimmt dass auch
diese kinder müssen wir zum frühest
möglichen zeitpunkt einbinden das heißt
wir müssen den verfassungsrechtlichen
grundsatz der chancengerechtigkeit ernst
nehmen chancengerechtigkeit ist keine
sache von warmen worten sondern von
sozialen realitäten und was wir diesen
kindern die nie eine chance hatten die
mit sechs jahren schon verloren waren
was wir den an chance nicht gegeben
haben das müssen wir über
verteilungsgerechtigkeit dann später
über transferleistungen müssen wir das
ausgleichen
und im grunde genommen sind diese
transferleistung nichts anderes als eine
entschädigung premier für hassan dafür
dass man ihm nie eine reale chance
gegeben hat in der schule und diese
ganzen früh fördermaßnahmen die werden
auch in der schweiz heißt diskutiert
soll man darf man muss man da stellt
sich ja auch die frage dem gehirn
eigentlich die kinder wenn sie sagen sie
wollen eine pflicht für einen in
deutschland wird das kindergarten heißen
bei unserer als eine kita ab drei jahren
dann nehmen die ein stück weit den
eltern die kinder weg das mache ich wenn
ich die kinder mit sechs jahren in die
schule schicke auch und man darf das
auch schon früher würden sie sagen aber
dass das motiv
dafür ist für sie die chancengleichheit
das motiv ist die chancengleichheit und
die chancengleichheit nur ein ganz ganz
wichtiger wert in dieser gesellschaft
seien menschen sind unterschiedlich sind
unterschiedlich begabt sie an
unterschiedliche neigung alles ohne
jeden zweifel nur das soll die schule
auch entfalten
aber zunächst mal soll jeder eine echte
chance bekommen
ich kann den wettbewerbsgedanken den
leistungsgedanken den
individualisierungs gedanken
den kann ich nicht verfolgen wenn ich
nicht vorher chancengleichheit
herstellen also das sind sozusagen die
beiden pole das ist einmal der pool der
sozialen gerechtigkeit und das andere
ist der liberale pohl der entfaltung von
jedem nach seinen möglichkeiten und die
müssen wir miteinander verbinden die
freiheit ist sozusagen zuweilen einfach
beschränkt werden auch zugunsten der
gerechtigkeit sie in die musi und ich
finde ehrlich gesagt das wird den
kindern meistens gar nicht so schlecht
tun in die kindertagesstätte zu gehen
wenn sie besser wären als sie
gegenwärtig sind das ist noch mal ein
riesen fest dass man aufmachen kann man
kann sich viele gedanken darüber machen
warum sind unsere kinder gerne nicht so
gut wie sie sein können vielleicht einen
eine letzte frage zu diesem thema noch
ich meine bildungspolitik ist ja immer
in einem zusammenhang zu sehen mit einer
größeren gesellschaftspolitik und die
frage die sich darstellt ist natürlich
auch wer soll das bezahlen
ich sehe da die finanzierung nicht als
hauptproblem
ich könnte aus unterschiedlichen
blickwinkeln argumentieren zunächst mal
kann nicht argumentieren dass alles geld
was wir jetzt in den ausbau von
kindergärten stecken in die
frühkindliche förderung durch
sprachlehrer nicht durch kinder
psychologen sozialarbeiter und so weiter
dass dieses geld peanuts im vergleich zu
dem was wir für diese kinder ausgeben
wenn sie mal erwachsene sind und sich in
diesem leben nicht zurecht finden wenn
sie im zweifelsfall kriminell werden
wenn sie von sozialen sicherungssystemen
abhängig sind
also da gibt es hochrechnungen sowohl
für die schweiz wie für deutschland
wichtig jetzt sparen zu wollen ja also
das ist das verhältnis ist ich weiß
nicht 1 zu 20 oder sowas also es lohnt
sich also gesellschaft sport wahnsinnig
viel geld wenn sie hier mehr investiert
und da sind sich glaube ich auch alle
einig ich glaube nicht dass das ein
streitpunkt ist für die schweiz gibt es
sehr genaue berechnungen
es gibt auch für deutschland sehr genaue
berechnungen und diese berechnungen
erklären sehr plakativ und eindrucksvoll
dass das gut investiertes geld ist der
zweite teil ist ich kann hier für
deutschland besser sprechen als für die
schweiz in deutschland bekommt jeder
kindergeld
das ist verfassungsrechtlich garantiert
deswegen hat sich anfassen sozusagen das
kriegt man während der ganzen kindheit
oder wenn das kind zur welt weil das
bekommt man in der zeit so lange die
kinder noch vom elternhaus abhängig sind
bekommt man diese szenen dazu laden sind
dass man hier würde ich so weit es geht
abschaffen beziehungsweise auf ein
minimum reduzieren
es ist zum beispiel auch für viele leute
die am unteren rand der gesellschaft ein
gutes motiv weitere kinder zu kriegen
weil sie dann wieder kinder geld kriegen
das ist verheerend
relativ hoch zu zeigen in deutschland
und das zweite ist ich bekomme auch
kindergeld
aber ich brauche kein kindergeld wollen
wir nicht 90 prozent des geldes was wir
für kinder geld ausgeben direkt in die
schulen in die kindertagesstätten und so
weiter machen die skandinavischen länder
machen dass die hälfte allen geldes das
in dänemark ausgegeben wird für kinder
geht in die schulen und in die
kindergärten bei uns ist es nur ein
verschwindender bruchteil und das dritte
ist wir werden in zukunft weniger lehrer
brauchen jetzt machen wir weniger kinder
und dann möchte ich ja in den schulen
etwa nur zwei hilft die lehrer haben und
zur anderen hälfte praktika und diese
praktika kosten im schnitt sehr viel
weniger geld wenn sie ein pensionierter
physiker sind am max-planck-institut der
seine aufgabe quasi verloren hat der
zuhause ist seiner frau auf die nerven
geht den rasen niedermetzeln und eine
aufgabe brauchen wenn der schule geht
und über quantenphysik mit den begabten
und interessierten ein projekt anbietet
der will ja kein geld dafür aber da gibt
es ja auch streitereien darüber dass
habe in der schweiz zum teil auch schon
ausgetestet mit unterschiedlichen
resultaten eine schwierigkeit ist auch
dass diese leute zum teil dann keine
pädagogische ausbildung haben und dass
es irgendwie auch schwierigkeiten gibt
in der frage der hierarchie zwischen
lehrperson und diesen diesen
hilfspersonen diesen praktiken die da
kommen aber vielleicht machen wir noch
einen schritt weiter wieder zurück zur
philosophie über die wir am anfang
gesprochen haben sie kritisieren ja
nicht in diesem buch oder nur am rande
aber sie kritisieren ja auch immer
wieder die universitäten und sagen auch
die art wie an universitäten gelernt und
geforscht wird ist eigentlich passe das
ist so sollte man das nicht mehr machen
dennoch sind sie selber
honorarprofessorin lüneburg und in
berlin
warum haben sie diese professoren
angenommen wenn sie eigentlich so
kritisch sind gegenüber den dem
universitären system mögen also ich
glaube dass mehr als die hälfte aller
universitäten die wir haben in 20 jahren
nicht mehr besteht
was sagt das ist ganz einfachen grund es
gibt dinge in universitäten ähnlichen
schulen die sind sinnvolle und andere
sind sinnlos was sinnlos sind sind die
ganzen einführungsveranstaltungen diese
pflicht mäßig in allen fächern machen
müssen also sagen wir mal
volkswirtschaft oder betriebswirtschaft
sinn machen mikroökonomie 1
makroökonomie eins und zwei so diese
veranstaltung macht und der user in
einem privat prozent oder ein professor
der nicht gut erklären kann
der liest und sich was vom blatt ab dann
sitzen 1000 schüler in köln sind mehr
als 1000 studenten die sitzen alle in
der aula ja verstehen fast nix und so
weiter um professionell vorgetragen auch
nicht gerade von dem hellsten stern am
baum und diese ganze veranstaltung des
zeitverschwendung
da können sie sich von einem
nobelpreisträger über e-learning der
software kommen lassen da wird ihnen das
erklärt von jemand der das absolut
beherrscht und er ist brillant erklären
kann also diese vorlesung von der ich
gerade sprache gesprochen habe die
stammt aus dem mittelalter
durch vorlesungen stammen aus dem
mittelalter als noch einer ein buch
hatte und der rest nicht lesen konnte
sie machen den sie in ihre vorlesungen
frei komplett frei und natürlich hat das
auch ein gewissen showcharakter nicht
damit die leute dabei sind aber wenn man
eine vorlesung gemacht wie in lüneburg
über erkenntnistheorie und descartes
erklärt und dergleichen frei lebendig
anschauliches erklären nicht vom blatt
ablesen
aber so rockig hinaus will ist ich will
nicht die universitäten gänzlich
abschaffen
ich will diese art von absoluten
veranstaltungen abschaffen also das
meiste grundstudium kann man besser zu
hause machen als man es in der uni
machen kann
universitäten brauchen wir ähnlich viele
schulen für was anderes wir brauchen
kleine feine gute universitäten mit
einem teamgeist einem spirit mit
seminaren in denen die engagierten
studenten sich wechselseitig begegnen
ihr austausch miteinander pflegen können
vielleicht auch gemeinsame projekte
machen entwickeln können
das heißt also für diese art von von
geistigen floh
dafür brauchen wir universitäten aber
wir brauchen sie nicht um grundlagen
wissen zu vermitteln was sie am pc sehr
viel besser und schneller lernen können
der nobelpreisträger den können sie
wieder zurück scrollen wenn sie was
nicht verstanden haben sondern sie
natürlich viel effektiver als in so
einer schlecht bevor ich denke da zurück
und adorno mit seiner kritik an der
massenkultur der gesagt habe das ist
irgendwie alles eine verdummung der
gesellschaft man verkauft die
gesellschaft für blöd wenn man ihn als
häppchen gerecht in einer show war
packte sie transportiert sondern es ist
halt einfach so man muss sich da noch
reinknien bücherlesen komplizierte texte
zum risiko lesungen ja also es ist ich
setze ja nicht vor der show also lesen
müssen sie genauso und am ende schreiben
sie auch eine arbeit und das ist
übrigens sehr viel schwieriger wenn ich
jetzt aus meinem eigenen büchern
vorlesen würde wie dies viele
professoren machen
dann wissen die studenten nachher ganz
genau was in einer klausur drankommt und
höre nicht zu wenn die studenten hier zu
hören wissen sie nicht was nachher in
der klausur drankommt sie sind also
gezwungen viel aufmerksamer dabei zu
sein zumal ich übrigens in dem moment wo
ich das erzähle gar nicht weiß was
später in der klausur ankommt ich
bewundere sich wie ihr selbstvertrauen
wie sie das erzählen wie sie einerseits
auf der bühne der öffentlichkeit präsent
sind bücher schreiben dann sind sie
universitäts-professor und zwei
universitäten haben sie manchmal auch
selbst reifen natürlich ich habe viele
selbstzweifel und ich bin ja auch gerade
für das buch über die schule sehr vielen
kritiken ausgesetzt und ich denke sehr
ernsthaft bei diesen kritiken darüber
nach es ist nur so dass die meiste
kritik ist relativ stereotyp und nicht
besonders interessant ich habe eine
einleitung geschrieben in der ich gesagt
habe es gibt drei freund feind linien in
der bildungsdiskussion und die müssen
wir überwinden
das erste ist die leute die das system
von außen kritisieren und jedem system
arbeiten also ein lehrer sagt der soll
sich mal 30 jahre in einer hauptschule
stellen und vor erziehungs schwierigen
pubertierenden soll der mal anfangen was
zu erzählen werde hat keine ahnung was
heißt lehrer meinen meistens dass jemand
von außen sehen ich kritisieren darf
das ist natürlich völlig falsch
politiker werden auch von nicht
politikern kritisiert und zwar sehr
reichlich taxifahrer werden auch
kritisiert wenn sie schlecht fahren von
leuten die selber keine taxifahrers ist
ein kennzeichen wo der einer
gesellschaft und dass man sich von außen
kritisieren lassen muss trotzdem habe
ich diesen vorwurf hunderte von malen
gehört
eine zweite konfliktlinie besteht darin
dass es menschen gibt die sagen alles
das was ich erzähle ist gar nicht neu
und das ist bis zu einem gewissen grade
richtig ich meine stellen sie sich mal
vor ich hätte mich eingeschlossen in
mainz studiert zimmer hätte nichts zur
kenntnis genommen und hätte innerhalb
von drei jahren irgendetwas ausgebrütet
was überhaupt keine bezugspunkt zu all
dem bestehenden hat das wäre ja völlig
absurd gewesen
das heißt natürlich gucke ich überall
was gibt es und wie kann man aus dem was
es gibt etwas gutes bauen das ist die
eigentliche aufgabe und auch herleiten
warum wir das bauen müssen
und dann ist die dritte konfliktlinie
geht immer daran besteht zwischen links
und rechts
das haben wir immer noch das heißt wenn
ich sage in den zukünftigen berufswelten
werden wir fähigkeiten haben die in den
schulen nicht trainiert werden
dann kommt sofort die kritik von links
er sagt albrecht will die leute für die
wirtschaft so schneider
wenn ich aber stattdessen schreibe es
geht darum die potenziale des kindes zu
entfalten und jeder nach salat und weise
dann kommen die leute aus der wirtschaft
und sagen was ist das hier für eine
kuschel pädagogik die kann ja keiner
gebrauchen in wirklichkeit hängt das
eine ganz eng mit dem anderen zusammen
aber die reflexe die stereotypen mit den
menschen in der bildungsdiskussion
argumentieren sie kommen ganz ganz
schnell aber ab und so lese ich ganz
intelligente kritiken und was meinen sie
wie lange ich darüber nachdenke
und da werden sie auch aus vermittler
gefragt und um nehmen diese position
einen geben sie versuchen die
verschiedenen linien irgendwie zusammen
zu bringen
jetzt noch einmal zurück zur
universitären philosophie in buchen mit
dem sie eigentlich berühmt geworden sind
dieses buch wer bin ich und wenn ja wie
viele
da beginnen sie damit dass sie sagen
etwas was sie immer ein bisschen traurig
gestimmt hätte sei dass die philosophie
an den universitäten wirkungslos
verpufft muss denn philosophie eine
wirkung haben
unbedingt warum habe ich angefangen mich
für philosophie zu interessieren weil
ich fasziniert war von personen wie
sagte oder wie adorno oder ernst bloch
das waren philosophen die mich
beeindruckt haben und das waren
philosophen die man nicht nur deswegen
kennen weil sie fachaufsätze geschrieben
haben sondern die man auch kennt
aufgrund ihres gesellschaftlichen
wirkens ich meine sache ist es ist
absolute gegenteil eines deutschen
universitätsprofessors der literatur
gemacht der theaterstücke gemacht der
hat sich
politisch engagiert ist durch die ganze
welt gereist hat sich auch eine menge
irrtümer fabriziert aber er war eine
eminent wichtige person um den
gesellschaftlichen diskurs seinerzeit zu
bündeln und das ist einer der gründe
warum philosophie interessant ist und
zwar auch außerhalb der universitäten
interessant ich bin nicht dagegen dass
es eine fachwissenschaftliche forschung
an den universitäten gibt aber die
relationen ständig wenn sie sich mal
anschauen wie sind im deutschsprachigen
raum universitätsprofessoren für
philosophie besetzt dann haben sie zur
einen hälfte historiker also leute die
absolute experten sind über kant über
hegel oder platon von denen aber nur
sehr sehr wenige sich mit fragen der
gegenwart beschäftigen sondern ihre
aufgabe darin sehen etwas historisches
zu erklären der andere teil ist besetzt
mit vertretern analytischen philosophie
also das ist ein hoch ausgeprägte form
des denksport ist wo man sich mit
formaler logik beschäftigt mit sprach
logik und der soll auch sehr viele sowie
die versucht verständlich zu bleiben die
analytischen philosophie ist für
verleihen komplett unverschämt aber
absolut sicher nicht alle aber die
allermeisten sind komplett
unverständlich das ist eine hochgradig
spezialisierte fachwissenschaft ich
würde mich selber der analytischen
philosophie treu ich wollte ich schon
mal nach freue mich wenn sie das
verständlich machen aber die meisten
texte der analytischen philosophie sind
sehr schwer verständlich und jetzt haben
wir das große problem dass in die
allermeisten analytischen philosophen
eigentlich den gegenstands bezug
verloren haben nämlich das was dann wenn
du so viel interessant ist also fragen
von sinn und bedeutung und wie soll ich
leben und auch ethik ethik ist kein
thema der analytischen philosophie
metall jedoch nicht meter et aber mit
system angewandte ethik hat doch auch
die ganze ausprägungen der sagen dir
angelsächsischen philosophie ja aber der
hauptgegenstand also in der quasi der
klassischen lehre der analytischen
philosophie ist ethik eine metaphysische
frage die nicht gegenstand bereich ist
sondern was ich mache ist nachdenken
über ethik in also ich denke über das
zustandekommen von moral und den
spielregeln von moral und den sätzen in
demokratische aussagen auf jeden fall
noch folgendes hinaus also die eine
hälfte hat weitgehend nicht
ausschließlich ausnahmen bestätigen die
regel den gegenstands bezug verloren und
die andere also die historische
forschung
den gegenwartsbezug und das beschreibt
in etwa das thema machen nun freue ich
mich natürlich dass es viele junge
wissenschaftler gibt junge professoren
gibt die daraus auch ausbrechen wollen
also ich bin unglaublich optimistisch
aber dieses ausbrechen ist nötig nicht
jeder muss sich einmischen aber viele
das eine ist da ist man fähigen
philosophie so zu transportieren dass
man sich versteht oder auch ist man
fähig oder willens ist man daran
interessiert probleme aufzugreifen in
der forschung die da draußen real
existieren und ich glaube da gibt es
ganz viele beispiele
es gibt viele philosophen in der
angewandten ethik die sich um
klimagerechtigkeit kümmern die
reproduktionsmedizinischen fragen
abhandeln hier und forschung ist ein
thema die ganze frage des inhalts - wird
von philosophen aufgegriffen
die andere frage ist wenn man das in der
forschung macht wie möchte man sich dazu
äußern in talkshows möchte man auch in
zeitungen dazu interviews geben finden
sie denn da gibt's mit pflicht das zu
tun
ich würde nicht sagen es gibt eine
pflicht aber man muss gute gründe haben
dies nicht zu tun
was ist diese forschung wert wenn sie
hoch intelligent fragen der praktischen
ethik behandelt fragen des klimawandels
mit den mitteln der analytischen
philosophie angeht wenn sie nichts
anderes sind als briefe an freunde
ja wenn sie einen text schreiben der
adressiert ist an 50 andere zu einer
community von 300 400 anderen die in der
lage sind das zu lesen und das zu
verstehen und das ganze bleibt immer in
dieser welt gefangen dann wird sich
nichts in dieser gesellschaft zum
positiven ändern
jetzt sage ich nicht jeder in dieser
community ist verpflichtet deswegen der
talkshow zu ihren wird wahrscheinlich
auch nicht eingeladen arbeitet wenn es
einige gibt die das machen und die das
nach außen tragen und diese erkenntnis
stände für menschen aufbereitet die
diese texte gar nicht lesen können dann
ist das sehr sehr wichtig für die
philosophie und sehr sehr wichtig für
die gesellschaft
gucken wir mal von der anderen seite die
nachfrage nach philosophie nacht public
philosophie ist ja da also ihre bücher
verkaufen sich wie verrückt wenn sie
irgendwo auftreten dann sind die hallen
voll
warum glauben sie denn dass sich so
viele leute die philosophie
interessieren ich glaube dass es recht
einfach dadurch zu erklären dass die
menschen heute sehr viel zeit haben über
sich und das leben nachzudenken und sehr
viel geld in materiellen umständen
zu leben indem sie sich keine
existenzsorgen machen müssen und diese
kombination weg den sinn für das
nachdenken
wir leben heute in einer sehr
komplizierten lebenswelt in der wir uns
sehr vieles aussuchen können wir können
heute einige wichtige fragen in unserem
leben selber entscheiden zum beispiel
welche religion wir für besonders
überzeugend halten aber genau so können
wir haben wir heute eine freie
partnerwahl in der liebe das hat es über
jahrtausende nie gegeben da wurde man
einfach verheiratet auch in unserem
kulturkreis
sie können heute entscheiden bauer zu
werden sie können entscheiden nach
australien auszuwandern sie können
entscheiden ein ehrgeiz darauf zu legen
bei einer bank karriere zu machen und so
weiter sie wissen aber nicht was macht
mich glücklich davon und sie sind auf
der suche nach einem optimalen leben
es ist aber nicht vorgezeichnet was für
sie das optimale leben ist und das weckt
den sinn für das nachdenken
sie fangen eine grundsätzliche fragen zu
stellen und das ist quasi das
einfallstor dafür dass menschen sich so
sehr für philosophie interessieren
übrigens nicht erst seit ein paar jahren
und auch nicht wegen meiner bücher
sondern das machen sie schon seit 30 40
jahren wenn sie mal gucken wie sehr sich
fernöstliche philosophie verkauft hat in
den 70er und 80er jahren also die all
diese buddhistischen weisheitslehren
millionenauflagen viel größer als die
auflagen meiner bücher ich habe
vielleicht mit meinen büchern ein ganz
bisschen dazu beigetragen dass das
augenmerk auch wieder auf den schatz der
abendländischen philosophie gerichtet
wurde ich bin auch wahrlich nicht der
einzige darauf aber dass ein bisschen
gebündelt hat und das ist das schöne
daran aber philosophische fragen
beschäftigen die leute spätestens seit
den 70er jahren sehr massiv
dieses buch wer bin ich und wenn ja wie
viele
da steht glaube ich ziemlich am ende der
satz füllen sie ihre tage mit leben und
nicht ihr leben mit tagen das klingt für
mich fast schon so wie eine
psychologische ratgeberliteratur es gibt
zwar einzelne momente wo man bedenkt wo
vermischt sich das denn bei ihnen also
ratgeberliteratur ist eine literatur die
die leute kaufen weil sie erwarten dass
sie da zählt sich ihre tipps kriegen wie
sie reich werden wie sie eine glückliche
beziehung wie sie den sinn des lebens zu
entdecken
mit dieser literatur habe ich überhaupt
gar nichts zu tun philosophie ist ja
nicht das leben von einfachen antworten
wenn es die der bewertungsverfahren sie
nicht langweilig
bevor sie hängen die zehn regeln einer
gelingenden beziehung und das
funktioniert alles wissen und das
funktioniert alles trotzdem nicht das
ist ja der grund warum ratgeberliteratur
sich so gut verkauft weil sie nicht
funktioniert sonst bräuchte man ja für
jeden bereich nur ein buch das würde man
lernen und dann hätte man ein
gelingendes leben
und weil das alles nicht funktioniert
hat das weiß hier philosophie natürlich
auch jetzt das ziel philosophische
bücher nicht tipps zu geben sondern
intelligenter über sich selbst
nachzudenken aber das ist doch ein tipp
wer das ist doch kein tipp versuchen sie
das mal in der praxis real umzusetzen
dann wissen sie immer noch nicht was sie
tun soll
das ist ein philosophischer tipp es ist
zumindest ein satz den man sich auch
ganz gut aus zitaten kühlschrank
vorstellen könnte ich habe gar nichts
dagegen es gibt ein paar sätze aus wer
bin ich denn schon mal gelegentlich in
solchen zitat sammlungen oder sowas
auftauchen ich glaube das ist kein
großes verbrechen weil sie werden auch
bei vielen bedeutenden philosophen des
abendlandes promos finden die sich an
den kühlschrank hängen können also wir
würden einige einfachen sprechen wir
noch ein bisschen über ihren
philosophischen zugang oder ihren
philosophischen hintergrund wenn sie
jetzt einen tipp geben müssten was
könnte man wenn aus der klassiker die
traktur lesen wenn man jetzt gerne einen
originalen philosophischen text lesen
möchte die man hat so kennt kommt jugend
hegel was interessiert sie wo denken sie
legen sie das mal das ist interessant
wäre ein ganz großes problem besteht
natürlich darin dass sie die
allermeisten wesentlichen texte der
philosophie ohne eine entsprechende
philosophische vorbildung gar nicht
lesen können also als laie können sie
weder regel lesen
euro sollen noch schelling das verstehen
sie nicht das sind jetzt aber auch
gerade wissen die am schwierigsten
die deutschen idealisten die schreiben
hat sich jetzt nicht gerade diese stärke
auch noch ein schönes beispiel dafür
auch heidecker und das sind eigentlich
texten diese ganz ganz schwer selber
lesen können deswegen bleiben wir erst
mal nur diejenigen übrig die sie ohnehin
gut lesen können also sie können john
stuart mill
ein ganz großer bedeutende
angelsächsischer philosoph den können
sie gut lesen sie können auch jugend
können sie ganz gut lesen und vieles von
dem was der video umgeschrieben hat das
in den aktuellen debatten um die
hirnforschung wieder ausgesprochen
aktuell als einstiegsdroge sagt ich
jemals das wunderbar plattform zu lesen
weil es in dialogen geschrieben ist weil
es eine gewisse fähigkeit hat sogar ein
bisschen humor drin ist und der
klassische lieblings philosoph aller
leute die nicht philosophie studiert
haben es entweder schopenhauer oder nie
zum weil sie auch beides relativ einfach
lösen können
aber ich glaube bevor man die chili ist
sollte man sich mit dem was von die
zertrümmert wird erstmal beschäftigt
haben deswegen halte ich den als
einstiegsdroge nichts für so ganz
geeignet wenn sie zu alt klug wenn man
liest ohne dass man die tradition gegen
die er sich stellt überhaupt verstanden
wobei sie einen gewissen er hinsichten
auch sachen aufnehmen die mieter
eigentlich gesagt habe nämlich zb diese
kritik haben der universität philosophie
die dominieren kann man irgendwas
zusammen kocht wenn man das liest denkt
man irgendwie neuer so weit entfernt
sind sie von dieser kritik zumindest
nicht sehen sie ich finde ja die
philosophischen fakultäten und
universitäten allerdings eine wahnsinnig
gute idee und meine kritik ist ja die
eines liebhabers das ist ja nicht die
eines feindes
es ist ja so dass ich immer denken
mensch das kann man doch alles viel
besser machen das ist eigentlich der
gedanke der dahinter steht waren sie
nicht gerne studiert ich hatte viele
langweilige professoren aber ich hatte
auch ein paar gute und es gab auch ein
paar gute die mich entzündet haben und
dieses interesse gemacht denn ich hätte
gern mehr gute das ist eigentlich das
worauf ich hinaus will ich will dass die
persönlichkeit ausbildung auch eine
andere ist also wir haben sehr viele
leute diese intelligente texte schreiben
die aber für die lehre nicht geeignet
sind und da muss man sich einfach sagen
warum bieten die lehrveranstaltungen
oder müssen die lehrveranstaltungen
anbieten warum haben wir nicht auch mehr
vermittler die einzig man überblicks
wissen vermitteln mir ist in meinem
studium nie einen überblick wissen über
die philosophie vermittelt worden
es ging von anfang an umfasst seminare
ich konnte mich dann um ein problem der
der der logik beiträge oder sowas
kümmern hochkompliziertes teil aber ich
konnte frege nicht einordnen in der
philosophiegeschichte ich konnte das
problem ganz zu meinem machen und die
universitäten müssen beides machen also
sie müssen sowohl dieses überblicks
wissen besser vermitteln sie brauchen
leute die das gut erklären können und
natürlich brauchen sie auch die
hochqualifizierten hoch differenzierten
forscher also ich will einfach eine viel
lebendigere universitäts kultur das ist
das wovon ich träume
also wenn wir es ganz wohl eher sagen
das was ich an debattenkultur in meiner
familie kannte das wünsche ich mir auch
an den hochschulen und die
debattenkultur ist leider an den
hochschulen im zuge des bologna
prozesses sehr sehr viel geringer würden
wir noch ein riesenfass auftun
zum schluss herr precht was glauben sie
sollte die philosophie sich vornehmen
welche themen warten da draußen auf die
sich die philosophie jetzt stürzen
sollte also ich glaube ein riesen thema
nur ein beispiel zu geben das geld
also die die regelung der finanzwelt das
ist wird ein riesenthema sein was sonst
auch in den nächsten jahren beschäftigt
und es ist ein großes philosophisches
thema geld ist so ein vielschichtiges
schillerndes phänomen das dürfen wir
nicht den ökonomen überlassen
dazu kriegen nein ich werde jetzt die
nächsten buch über geld schreiben und
ein zweites thema was wichtig ist ist
natürlich alles was mit daten nur mit
der digitalen revolution zusammenhängt
also wie schaffen wir es den digitalen
supermächten wie google oder wie
facebook die stirn zu bieten und
ebenfalls ein wichtiges thema für
philosophen wäre europa also welches
europa ist wirklich wünschenswert und
wie kriegen wir das hin
vielen dank herr precht
[Musik]